hey youtubers its charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 4 video
the big question is who is lash I mean
we finally got a good look at him we
heard him speak for the first time
actually I'll go ahead and say this
first careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet I'm gonna
do this just a little bit differently
just because there are a couple really
important storylines and some
foreshadowing for the spin-off TV show
that I think is going on here starting
with number 5 in humans vs. lash so this
is funny in North Hollywood because it's
actually relatively close to where I
live but there's a bunch of Inhumans
from the previous settlement from the
second half of season 2 that have been
hiding out people that know Lincoln and
actually the the girl that multiplies
comes back she's the way that Coulson
found those people but lash gets there
first and it's a bloodbath the important
thing to come out of this though is the
idea that someone sent them an email
trying to bring their people together
and they implanted a virus helping track
them it turns out the email was from
this programmer who was working with
lash but the really interesting thing
about lashes is that he already knows
who the people are he knows their names
he just doesn't know how to find them
that's what the programmer was for so
really this whole episode becomes part
scooby-doo mystery like collecting clues
to see who lash might end up being you
know which person that we've already met
then to this Hydra storyline with Ward
then 3 the storyline with Fitz and
Simmons trying to get back to that other
planet on the number 4 Fitz finds out
what Simmons is trying to do in his
negative is hunter storyline seems like
he is obsessed with getting ward
Bobbi is obsessed with getting back into
action to save him Simmons actually
seems a little more positive it doesn't
seem quite as negative as that Hydra
storyline like anytime you go back into
action of course there's gonna be a
shitstorm there'll be consequences it
just doesn't seem like they're spinning
this Simmons thing it is quite a
negative light as the Hydra storyline
the only bad part is is they they cut to
black the minute Simmons was like okay
I'm gonna tell you everything now the
whole story the leading theory right now
about where that other planet is is that
it is Marvel's Hell as an H e l the
Asgardian version of the afterlife which
is an actual run like a physical realm
that you can go to there's a sprinting
theory now that agents of shield will
slowly tie in with thor ragnarok I mean
of course it'll tie in with it it's just
that thor ragnarok has a ways off it's a
long ways off this other planet could
just be the conduit for that they did
say that the TV
with tie-in more with the movies so this
is just the easy in but the thing is
isn't it tying it to the Thor movies
kind of pulls it away from the Kree
because the Kree don't necessarily cross
paths with the Thor movies or at least
yet they're gonna take all the movie
universes when we get to Avengers
infinity war and just like mash them up
in a blender so so eventually like
guardians things will clash with
Avengers things will clash with Thor
things in outer space but it's not
confirmed that it's hell it's just
another theory but I've never been more
interested to find out what it was that
happened to Simmons there that she's so
eager to get back to oh and by the way
Simmons when she was talking to Andrew
was like I'm not one of your Inhumans I
feel like that's the show telling us
that she's not an inhuman so cross
Simmons off the who is lash list like
the Liz's gets shorter and shorter to
throughout the episode I do like the
idea that lashes a female character I
don't think that's the case though on
the number three
Coulson versus Rosalind so the funny
thing here is that they're actually
working together in a fairly positive
way even though Daisy completely hates
the idea they definitely have more
chemistry than any of the other two like
you know pairings on the show it would
probably be terrible if they ever
actually became a thing like Coulson's
relationship with the cellist was so
much more interesting when we didn't
know who she was when they made it an
actual thing on the show it was kind of
nice that they paid that off but I
didn't necessarily feel like it made
things better like it made that story
better actually putting a face to her
even though the minute Daisy explained
to Mack I saw a last change into a human
it could be anybody and then like the
curtain gets pulled back in it's Rosalyn
yeah I definitely do not think that lash
is Rosalind that's just them messing
with us I will however high-five the
writer that wrote that in there was just
a great moment played for comedy on the
number two main hunter versus Ward so
the big thing here is that if they kill
Ward then he would kill Andrew but
hunter obviously not having any of it so
he goes after Ward anyway he can't be
reasoned with he can't get over the rage
of what Ward did to Bobby so he just he
just goes after me he's like Sorry mate
so what I think they're doing is just
laying groundwork to create you know
create tension within the group between
May and hunter for hunter and Bobby to
go off on the spin-off TV series that's
the Marvel Most Wanted TV series they
announced they're making a pilot they're
trying to turn it into a thing it's kind
of like a mockingbird TV show they're
just calling it Marvel's
wanted it's gonna be hunter and Bobby so
what better reason for them to leave
there's a huge amount of tension over
what happens to Andrew between May and
Hunter
that's just a small part of it really I
mean you have mockingbird over here on
the side that's been benched by Colson
who is just getting more and more angry
and not being able to do anything he's
like you're not ready you're still
recovering
you're still rehabbing at a certain
point she has to get off the bench
finally onto my number one WTF moment
and reveal Andrew might be dead killed
by jr. von Strucker but here's what I
think is going on I think this is a
complete misdirect I think that Andrew
is either saved by an inhuman or he is
lash himself the joke here is that you
just see the feet in a pool of blood and
jr. von Strucker freaking out like he
saw something that he wasn't prepared
for
he was probably prepared to kill Andrew
so if Andrew was actually dead he would
probably be making like an evil smile
here he wouldn't be flipping his
this is the kind of face that someone
has when someone surprises you so maybe
Andrew did something or changed into
lash and it freaked him out but
regardless of how he was saved whether
he turned out to be lash or whether some
other person saved him in a pinch I
think that this character that's dead on
the ground here is one of those Hydra
characters it'll be a fun reveal next
week I don't think they'll make us wait
too long before showing us what ended up
happening here but the problem with
Andrews storyline is is that it's so
much tied up in the in this May story
lightly they have this history together
they say that he took off during the
break like whenever they were off on
vacation by themselves I feel like they
haven't developed those characters
enough together I mean like Mae is
relatively well developed but the Andrew
character is not so I'm just emotionally
I'm not feeling their connection it's
just not working for me on screen yet I
know they have history but I'm not I'm
not feeling it I just feel like we need
to spend more time with those characters
here's just an idea though there's
there's no real evidence for this yet
but what if Andrew bolted on their
vacation like Mae said that he took off
you didn't like what you saw so you left
maybe he left because he turned into an
inhuman that would definitely throw some
fuel on the fire that is the theory that
he might be lash that there's still a
couple candidates I know a lot of people
are wondering if Banks is lash he's
definitely a possibility but he seems a
little bit crazier and lash seems like
he's trying to help people I'm not being
merciful this is necessary
like he's not vicious like he's not
hurting people intentionally he's just
trying to clean a big mess up let me
know in the comments though who do you
think lashes right now do you think it's
one of the good characters and they
change the comics that that's not
necessarily the way lashes in the comics
I have to wait to see the actual
storyline play out before deciding you
know whether or not changing his story
from the comics would be a good thing
sometimes it's good sometimes it's
totally okay and I don't mind them
changing comic book stuff sometimes ends
up being terrible so we just have to
wait and see so option one is is that
lashes like some character that we
haven't met yet option two he's one of
the good characters and Coulson's gonna
have to deal with it it's gonna create a
lot more tension inside the group
especially if said inhuman is someone
that may is romantically involved with
so really important to new episode of
arrow is gonna post tonight I'll do my
video right after it airs Malcolm Merlyn
is coming back we're going back to Nanda
Parbat there's gonna be a whole bunch of
resurrection Lazarus Pit stuff going on
so be sure to check it out
well you guys wait for all that stuff to
post you can click here to watch the
Star Wars trailer again I'm just gonna
I'm gonna post it like every single
video this week just rewatch it like a
billion times and you can click here to
catch up with the flash from last night
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys a
little bit
you